verdaderamente es un cambio en la
posición que venía teniendo la iglesia
donde pues hasta ahora se guardaba
silencio el
pontífice en santo padre por primera vez
en
muchos años expresa este este tipo de
palabras de vergüenza del mea culpa ante
este tipo de hechos pero por un lado
aunque no lo dice de alguna manera de
corazón por por esta terrible número
unos 330.000 menores de edad que habrían
sido víctimas de pederastia de
pederastia en la iglesia francesa pues
esta mañana es el resultado del primer
juicio que se realiza en el vaticano
contra pues dos sacerdotes acusados de
abuso sexual el ex rector del pre
seminario pio décimo y también contra un
sacerdote que pues era uno de los
formadores en ese momento también un
menor de edad gabriel de martinelli
acaba puede tener una sentencia y el
veredicto ha sido la prescripción por
ausencia de prueba y esto es pues que
efectivamente absuelve a ese dos
acusados por el delito de abuso sexual
entonces por un lado tenemos un hecho
que es la absolución de esta admisión
también le pregunta ahora qué acciones
concretas ha tomado el papá francisco
desde su llegada al vaticano en
dirección a detener la pederastia
pues en un principio este primer juicio
que se está realizando dentro de las
puertas del vaticano es una acción
importante nunca antes había sucedido y
pues se inició durante el año pasado a
pesar de la reciente del reciente
anuncio de la absolución y por supuesto
de poder
generar una política en la cual permite
que todos aquellos clérigos que sean
acusados de abuso sexual sean juzgados
por la justicia de sus respectivos
países una acción que puede ser bastante
revolucionaria recordemos que el
vaticano la iglesia a la institución de
la iglesia se mueve a un paso distinto a
una velocidad distinta de lo que se
mueve muchas veces otros estados
pues daniel gracias por toda la
información